welcome to Jim Norton and Sam Roth I
Thomas Haden Church again it's really
nice to meet you and who is it was why I
was on Ellis not not to can't hear a
damn thing I was on jason Ellis awhile
back and they were talking about that
you had made a big leap from or maybe
are you still Opie no no no I that's a
new name I but you I was working with
Opie yeah now yeah yeah now I'm doing
that now it's you're in Jim yeah yeah
congratulations
well thank you something that happened
months ago
what still I mean to get congratulations
right you get a raise I don't know if
you heard but Thomas Haden Church is oh
I think we're doing something here we
need to renegotiate yeah well the
Bottomley who's congratulating you not
me well I get condolences so we've been
having me on you guys that's usually the
opening kind of insignificant comment to
make right on my side
no seriously significant on your side we
appreciate I wouldn't [ __ ] would be I
couldn't I couldn't I did enough to rest
your radio with the [ __ ] getting
around the language and it was too much
it was difficult it was awful yeah
people I liked you guys had to skirt
around my language do you was terrible
nobody's ever everybody always says that
they go like well you know the satellite
radio part of the fun and part of what
makes it funny is that they can't do
that can so that was the origin of
satellite resent the [ __ ]
satellite you can say I just I wish you
can stop singing into a mirror you know
it's one of those things where the
language people like well I always like
what you get on language but people you
know they didn't say that when you watch
a porno nobody's a guy I hate when they
showed the dick in the mouth I like what
you can imagine it I don't know and if
the wrist I hate it when they say the
f-word
yeah no porn yeah and at the risk of
being a shill for HBO
you know that nobody sits there like HBO
and literally roll
don't put out the top 100 TV shows right
they made a list of the top 100 one is
some yesterday number one is Sopranos
number two is the wire they gets all HBO
shows that have plentifully used words
like [ __ ] [ __ ] ice Lance's
photo today on the way in the show
Travis by the way giant bus had with him
and Jessica Parker there I just was over
at a Good Morning America and there was
a bill like a huge building a buddy of
mine you know every actors dream to be
on the side of a building and on Sunset
Boulevard yeah that big one right on the
jaw as I dude you look like Sam Elliott
yeah so are you on that building that
giant when you determine that sign that
there's a giant Doheny yep cuz the donee
any sign yet unless you know he had a
selfie stick holding the dough he
history more important that's a massive
[ __ ] you I've been on that building
happen I'm lying I thought you might
want to have no I have a significant a
second yeah that is a great one though
that's how you know they believe in a
show where they can that's gotta be
expensive to get unless HBO owns that I
don't know I don't know if they do other
stuff there they just roll a huge banner
down and right there for the day do
people can vote can people see out the
windows who live in the building like
that what's got a giant thing I don't I
think they go around the windows but I
think that particular building is
windowless like maybe it's a prison on
Sunset Boulevard yeah the great sunset
prison you know I I don't think there's
windows but there probably are yeah you
know only where your eyes are you know
they have those in Pittsburgh and
Pittsburgh you go down whatever road it
is and you can see the jail and the
windows are really narrow slits sounds
like a strong trooper helmet like so you
can get some air and look out the window
that seems really unpleasant yeah that
sucks being in jail slow torment yeah I
mean there's worst parts about jail
being force-fed dick
I worse than losing a few yeah I can't
see the river anymore but I can see this
guy pubes at the fun of satellite so
don't don't feel obligated to talk about
the show we're talking about on the
buildings and the like Jim was sort of a
kind of sweet but sort of a beleaguered
sorority like I need to talk we're
talking about UFC fighters and then we
switch over to Sarah Jessica Parker
talking about the show a little bit
moaning in pre-suit yeah and I liked
what I saw
but again the password HBO's password
system has got to be fixed because I got
logged out and it would not accept my
UFC unfiltered password sounds like user
error I don't so much through the
episode and they just they're trying to
read my iris and they're just like
there's nothing happening you're
blinking a lot more yesterday though
yeah higher energy and we were talking
about something I make him feel
comfortable
yeah you know I'm his I'm his rock yeah
it is the word you looking for sport
well on a radio for bad this is like
less than a week we have known each
other for a long time when we've
traveled a lot
no I know I'm the last professional
broadcaster I just broadcast like I just
I just do the show you know you and what
is it Covina and rich guy no don't they
I like shows on different channels and
different like morning and evening Drive
and I always get that sense anytime I go
by that they're on the mornings in the
evenings but like they live bicoastal or
something I think they're in LA I'm not
I don't really know their show yeah to
diminish them now but it seems like
they're on both mornings and evenings
I honestly don't know is that do you
know anything I like those guys a lot
another shoot well you know you were
saying yes
you're just getting a better shot she's
saying they are bicoastal and I think
they've been trading him around
timeslots instead okay Jim everything's
homoerotic you know questions store yeah
I didn't mean it like that
he's a PI it's not surprising it would
be interpretive the stuff everything is
kind of self reflexive with Jim
reflecting it's reflexive no self
reflecting I didn't sighs you could be
self-reflective self reflexive right
it's come toward I think I haven't
sandwich corrected as self reflexive oh
well when when a man is wrong he admits
he's wrong that's what happens when you
graduate college well I didn't cool drop
okay this show is called divorce do I
start wrapping up now no who's [ __ ]
late apologize were you like what time
I'm supposed to be I was a little late I
think I was supposed to be here at 10:00
sharp and we hung out downstairs for a
while and had a cappuccino with traffic
we're trying to get through security in
traffic and all that security submission
a super dated photo that was when I
auditioned for the Hulk Almighty show
that to the camera
are you kidding I'm not totally kidding
oh it's got a green this is how dumb I
am literal Jim I actually believe this
joke that is stupid
I know in the Angley version of the Hulk
so I got beaten on whoo it was Angley I
did it not John well yeah yeah yeah why
do you suppose people like well I was
able to get through the treacherous
waves of HBO and watch the show
good work yes good work so why I enjoyed
it very very much and I do I think
because it's like you get to watch other
people being miserable right like it's
just a joke or Travis enjoys this
it's like a terrible existence do you
think that like there's something innate
in people where they're like you know
what there's something comforting about
people being doing worse than me being
way more [ __ ] up there yeah that I am
sitting here masturbating naked with
french fries you know yeah I think there
is and I've discussed it with a lot of
other journalists although you have an
acumen for a perspective that I was on I
wasn't suspecting wasn't expecting no I
think that we attempt to take a very
personal sort of approach to what can be
a really horrific human experience which
is a family being torn apart it's not
just a husband and wife it's a family
sure and I do I sort of relish the fact
that there are scenes and there are
sequences throughout the ten episodes
that are sort of gonna be like a bit of
a look away because they whatever
however intimate the pain or even the
comedy but the comedy it comes out of
these people being ripped apart by
whatever betrayal or whatever other
circumstance ultimately can can tackle a
another wise healthy marriage it's
always fun to watch people who are
unhappier than watching people who are
happier there's something comforting
about relating to [ __ ] you never want to
hear about a good date I don't wanna
hear how's your marriage it's great blue
pressure marriage oh my god she [ __ ]
the bouncer tell me about it I want you
here when it's bad I want to hear when
it's terrible I'm not interested when
it's good so that's that's a good
concert version is there I've watched
the first two episodes so I mean like I
kind of see where the arc might go but
is there room to continue this on or is
this just a one season show no no they
they are hoping that it's it's gonna go
beyond one season because did you sign
up for one more season theoretically
wants the divorces a limited series now
but thank you know is you know I like
these things historically can drag on
for years with lawyers involved and
custody battles and all that kind of
[ __ ] but I really have no idea you know
it's like we just wanted to tell the
story
and make it sincere and identifiable but
unique just gonna throw it all the very
good I don't know you know to see I mean
I think there is no grand plan as long
as it's compelling right but there is
something built into the story that
allows you to it's not gonna go ten
seasons like Cheers
right now no divorce Cheers kind of
there's different polarity there I ain't
never been married I haven't I've been
engaged a couple of times and you know
both times that there was like hey you
know do you want to get married it's
suddenly and and maybe it's just me
maybe I brought it upon myself but it's
just suddenly there was more challenges
and concerns and you know do we have the
same goals and suddenly it just seemed
like what was kind of carefree became
just heaped upon by the big important
questions of where are we going to be
ten years from now and try and you know
it really you know I mean it just was
too much of a burden for those
relationships and and they did collapse
and it's you know I think you you have
to be a lot more self-aware when you
take on even the responsibility of
asking somebody to marry you you got to
be really self-aware that you know is it
it do we can we can we keep this up can
we hold this up can we is there are we
sturdy enough as a girlfriend-boyfriend
to keep this up and a lot of times it
doesn't work out and then sometimes
people are like yeah we fell in love
when we got married you know we only
knew each other six months and yet my
age now so many of those are just doomed
yeah one's the old school ones work like
that from the 50s you know I mean like
those marriages lasted for some reason I
don't know why because dude was going
off to Korea and then he didn't get
killed maybe that's what it is and
there's nothing about it's not that
there's not the choice that we have now
with all the internet stuff and divorce
was - it was stigmatized back then like
yeah you don't want to do is you think
so my students I love a good divorced
person good woman's got a paper in her
pocket with the inks still wet
I'm [ __ ] eating or [ __ ] immediately
you guys been right in there I'm right
in there did you get to like I felt like
it was an opportunity
you for you to unleash a lot of
frustrations because by the way if you
can see Sam's finger position right now
you want to smash his head with a
[ __ ] mallet that's what people who
are insightful this is how we he has his
fingers how would you describe that you
saw a Thomas there enraging what is this
ooh saw I know what that is but for him
it's like a pinch it's like a pinch of
paprika nice nicely played Sam Roberts
thank you it's a song of paprika what
his fingers rolling that's it but are
you able to get your frustrations out
through this show like you need to be an
angry sure that your wife character oh
yeah no we there's plenty of crossfire
and attacks and and but I mean you know
Sarah Jessica Parker and I even at the
outside we didn't want it to just be
constant hostile gunfire and skirmishes
and lawyers and you know and friends and
family like [ __ ] him and [ __ ] her and we
didn't want it to be like that at all
that's saying that there's none of that
because if you've seen the trailer you
know there's the the you know the the
middle flag is waving but yeah I mean
you know it's all inherent to what you
thought was sort of a petition and then
in this in the Brillion the stroke of a
party you did see the president in the
stroke of a party it's like hey I don't
love you anymore and I just recognized
that and I think if I don't love you
then I can't be married to you anymore
and it's like a thunderclap right you
know before that was like [ __ ] okay it's
raining but it seems like everything's
cool right you did a good job of like
setting up the fact that you guys were
miserable together but it was just like
an existing at the very beginning this
is such a superficial is it miserable
it's just unhappy you know she can't
tolerate me singing along with Coldplay
yeah she can't talk you know you just
ain't no way to each other way during
the bath water [ __ ] exactly I mean it's
a it's the stupid little insignificant
things but you know what eventually it's
like oh [ __ ] now we've got k2 in our
marriage and we have to
gaile it is it worth our while and age
sometimes it's not like I quoted this
song yesterday but I'm gonna do it again
do you know their songs Southern Cross
by crosby Stills and Nash I know it but
he does it's like we never fail to fail
because it was the easiest thing to do
mm-hmm and I think that sometimes a lot
of people like [ __ ] it you know I'm not
I don't want to fight I don't even this
is this right it's not it's not a good
enough fight it's I don't even I don't
want to win and I don't even give you
[ __ ] if I lose I don't want to be in the
fight right
did you really I'm sure you've been
asked about this a hundred times before
did you were you naked in the audition
for sideways yeah and the crazy thing is
that at the after we've been shooting
for a while and making small talk with
Alexander and I really and truly it was
like man you must have got tired of
seeing butts and you know and wieners
you know yeah uncircumcised junk you
know every other guy and he was like no
you're the only guy that did it they
told me that when I audition for The
Wonder Years they didn't want to do it
on scrubs but he's still just start on
scrubs you still stripped down naked and
they're like Jim no take it out well we
got a wrap unfortunately about what we
got a wrap we got at home we have to
that's what has to happen that's what
you do you just say like a gerbil trying
to find you know the birdseed yeah